hey aaron rodgers let's go to another
state let's go to wisconsin aaron
rodgers
threw his 400th career touchdown pass
yesterday the fastest the fastest in
nfl history to 400 touchdown passes and
you know some of the familiar names on
the list brady's on the list man he's on
the list
uh brett favre is on the list
but aaron rodgers was able to do it
in 193 games look at this look at this
he's a seventh quarterback with 400
touchdown passes
and these names these luminaries uh out
there
i think i think uh aaron rodgers is
getting
a lot of the credit you can't say he's
underrated
uh there's no further appreciation you
can take the aaron rodgers thing
but i want to know this though out of
all those guys
uh that we see there are the 400
touchdown pass guys
would you say because i know you've
mentioned this before i just want to
make sure we're clear on this
let's take phillip rivers out of the
conversation
i don't know if he belongs behind this
velvet rope
would you build a team with aaron
rodgers over any of those guys that you
see
in the lower third you say okay i'm a
team builder
i get to pick anybody i'm gonna start
oh you would yes
yes this is get patrick mahomes is
making this harder and harder to say
unequivocally but i've been saying for
years
for years this ain't a new thing saying
a new take
i mean you know that aaron rodgers for
me is the best that i've ever seen
played a position
um i love steve young's peak love it
love like early night early midnight
steve young look
i mean he was incredible he doesn't get
his is just due
any all-time quarterback conversation in
my opinion mourinho was my favorite
quarterback growing up
brady is the most decorated and that's
not a
that's not a slight most decorated along
with
no no but along with one of the best to
perform at the position
therefore he's the goat you combine
those two things he's the goat he's the
greatest
okay he's the greatest it's not like
he's just been along for the ride no
he's the guy
but in terms of a performer at the
position the guy who
at age thirty thirty older there are now
at age 37
just had his fifth 35
touchdown pass season got almost all
time
okay you know i ain't mad at it i like
it uh but
i i think when we have this conversation
and the
that where we're having a difference is
you do
think and i might even agree with you
like we agree on
on certain things about aaron rodgers so
you say hey maybe the
greatest performer you know throws the
prettiest ball plays the position better
than anybody ever seen and patrick
mahomes is on his way
but all aspects of quarterbacking
whatever you want to call it aaron
rodgers
performs that position better than
anybody ever that's where i stopped in
my opinion
and that's where i can't just oh i can't
just jump over that
because if i'm starting an organization
i'm not necessarily going with
especially on this list
uh and we know philip it was so those
seven guys
uh philip ripper's off the list because
i'm just sorry
i just don't know he's not in that class
no he's not
he's not that prolific and he's not
longevity but he's not in that class
that's the outlier that's the outlier
everybody else belongs
if i'm starting an organization i'm not
necessarily going with the best
performer
i'm trying to hit as many areas as i can
a guy may be great in some areas and not
so great in
others and so i'm just trying to think
about what i need for my i'm trying to
get as much as i can
my first building block and for the
building block i go with tom brady
over rogers but if i'm getting into a
contest of
who looks better doing it
okay sure that feels so dismissive that
feels
you know every time you say that every
it's such a backhanded compliment well
if you want to talk about
who looks better doing it you know if
you want to talk about
you know who's got this you know what
you know
who throws the better passes if you want
to talk about that kind of who cares
like you know like you know it's not
like we're talking about quarterbacking
you know if you want to talk
about the time you say it see it's no no
no no i love the way you saw
your excellent communicator it is always
within the context of like oh y'all
worry about the wrong things
y'all worry about who looks better that
was prettier you know
come on every time every time you just
argue with me you always want to act
like that doesn't matter and i've said
i'm not taking anything away from brady
i'm not saying brady's not excellent
but brady ate rogers and everything how
many people
tell you that come on sometimes i do
that this is not one of those times
you're actually being
you'll be trying to kill him with this
on the slick like yeah you know if
you're interested in who throws the
prettiest ball
and yeah rogers is your guy but you know
if you want that little if you want to
win football
the hammer in there you sound like the
boston people
if you if you want to win championships
you want to win football games and
brady's your guy he's like
okay all right i have lived here for the
last 20 plus years so i mean
come on right man okay um all right sure
but i think this is what i think of tom
brady you know what tom brady is
you know and the argument has changed
over the years thankfully
because it used to be either or i don't
like either or arguments in general
but it was you can only have one
or the other it can't be both so
in in the 80s and early 90s it was
if you want marino monsanto that's you
going to mourinho
if you want to win you go to montana
which is such tom brady's both
tom brady's both yeah yeah joe montana
it was the it was the analogy i made a
couple of years ago and then it was
mourinho montana and then it was
manning brady but here's the analogy i
made a couple years ago i think i did it
after the uh after the
the falcons come back is like you know
how in boxing
how there is like different belts and
then a champion will unify the belt
and it'll undispute the champion right
brady is the undisputed goat like he
unified the
talent stats longevity wins
all that he took all that together
everything that you would take from
everybody else
he put all that together into one title
mckinnon disputed
well let me ask you taking a wish if he
[ __ ] out i had oh i had a dope pivot but
go ahead
i still got it hold on go back to your
dog at that point
if you feel like he unified all the
belts then why aren't you giving him
that one
team building okay there you go that's
your guy because i prefer rogers
i prefer rogers hey thanks for watching
brother from another on youtube make
sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you